you were cool way before hipsters were
cold yeah you heard it right here all
those tips are dipping in school
oh my goodness pizza man where have you
been
why is everybody call me pizza man it's
when I'm captain miracoli what is
miracle a miracle yes miracle Oh a
miracle a miracle yeah Izzy we don't
have a much time and is a bigger warship
for it by the way I love that you know
like you must be miracle man because you
know that pizza is a miracle it is that
[Music]
should I call you mr. chasm call me
whatever you want just don't call me
late for dinner all right mr. miracle of
course what do you do you think no none
of me mad of the other guy
yeah I what I'd like to see him go up
against you because I don't think he'd
have a chance no you could literally
pizza him to death yeah yeah because I
pretend that I do a gluten-free pizza
but it's not gluten-free you know what I
mean okay that's how you're in yeah very
same dish so you a good guy or about it
going
I am I always wanted to be good but it's
like mugs then this guy comes up be a
fly he's like bulletproof yeah and I am
you know like yo this is crazy right
what are your superpowers superpowers
dude I don't even know how to pee in
this thing so the name itself stands for
the wisdom of Solomon the strength of
Hercules the stamina that was the power
of Zeus the courage of Achilles and the
speed of mercury yeah I thought he was
kind of okay you know you can slowly big
deal you know super speed super flights
he's 40 and he's a kid doesn't even know
what powers he's come had to work them
all out one by one with his with his
friend super strength super modesty
super modesty like talking about like
the most humble you know what I mean
yeah oh and then you know the fact that
I can transfer back and forth between uh
being a kid and an adult he can shoot
lightnings from his hands and
probably other things that we've and we
haven't see that we haven't explored yet
yeah that's great superpower
[Music]
this is superhero there's always a
supervillain yeah so who is this doctor
Savannah Savannah what kind of doctor AC
I I think he's an optometrist but you
know no it's an orthodontist that's what
I miss just fixing people's grills great
um he is
I'll have the Sims on my side so I've
got seven deadly sins that manifest
themselves out of my body he's a bit of
an evil genius no very smart guy but he
he was turned down and didn't get the
powers that Billy got which made him
really angry and you know because I
think now with this newfound power
really just wants to go make everybody's
life miserable
yes I'd like to see you try to take
those with your cutlery it doesn't work
you're like a bad guy
you nearly did the opposite of what a
superhero is supposed to do and your
superpowers or will I can talk to girls
yes that's just by virtue of being
Italian yes yes it's not a superhero
it's very nice to people
I can I can show them what time it is
how much time yes lunch time is execute
it is my costume is of course
great the one from Shazam's second
graders yes um how long did it take to
make the costume do you because he is he
looks much it took quite a while and
that while we were making it sack was in
the gym hitting the gym and eating a lot
of calories to to get the the proper
physique I've been in the gym now six
days a week for 18 months I mean it and
eating lots and lots of I wish pizza but
not things as tasty as pizza to get into
this you know the best shape of my life
which I'm super grateful for do we have
a scene in which you like the most and
Shazam I do love the convenience store a
lot because I mean that that's when he
first gets to actually confront bad guys
you know the the convenience store gets
robbed and he gets to stop this robbery
and really discover what he can do as a
super girl and it was a lot of fun to
shoot as well because it was the first
time we ever shot with with sack in the
suit so that's when we really felt that
okay this is actually gonna be something
great
you have full immunity you're dead
[Music]
welcome for not getting robbed why a
superhero so important well I think
superheroes are important and always
have been because heroes are important
and always have been you know viscom it
comes from 1939 1940s no extra that
that's the Second World War so post war
comics dealt with superheroes because
they needed to create somebody to fight
off the dark side and it's great to tell
the stories of good versus evil those
are you know just things that people
always respond to and certainly in our
movie it's great to see good triumphs if
you had an advice for from my movie what
should happen in my movie well you know
David has not committed yet to his next
project so I think maybe afterwards you
guys should chat a little bit yes could
make something happen
sure but with aliens of course are very
great and making compliments so if you
just want to take one compliment oh okay
it's 360 complements you can choose one
you just open it them that you can read
it but if you were cool way before
hipsters work old-school I think you had
a bad day so take three take three okay
you just can open open them up and reach
what is inside you are the most perfect
you there is that's really profound I
know yeah try another one another one
let's let's sample more of this wisdom
okay you are my hero
okay that's cool everybody talks about
the best and greatest superpower what do
you think is like the worst superpower
what's the worst superpower be probably
like explosive flatulence or something
like that like that wouldn't be you know
cuz like you know ripping a fart in
general he's like it says a difficult
thing to do it's embarrassing or acid
reflux white-tail that's the great
superpower yeah but is a super villain
super villain buddy likes acid reflux so
dr. sivana if you ever need me just take
this yeah and say the magic word the
pasta necklace the pastor necklace and
what do I say yeah Bobby D poopy poopy
poopy do I need to wear it
yeah left again I'm gonna humiliate
myself now for mr. pizza man here kept
them in actually my personal necklace I
was gonna say Bobby D Bobby oh yeah yeah
it works
Jesus Wow and we share a common a
superpower you're only a mortal self we
can speak German listen listen Deutsch
um I'm the einen Eric turn Angela Dawson
to Salah Mozart and dust dust field East
fantastisch daily baths
I wish you
silly names of my powers for become
yours
wait for you okay
[Music]
it's crazy right what are your
superpowers super for hours dude I don't
even know how to pee in this thing
[Music]
electricity manipulation
hyperspeed I'd like to purchase some of
your finest beer please
[Music]
is Kathy Sparkle fingers no it's not
it's not me that's not my name
those were like a bad guy
you really did the opposite of what a
superhero is supposed to do you're him
you're the hero
you're welcome we're not getting wrong
how old are you basically 15
[Music]
see that yeah you electrocuted a bus and
almost killed these people and then I
caught it
and they've tall buildings in a single
bound
[Music]